Hmm …
zart,
schmelzend,
lecker –
das ist vermutlich das Erste,
was einem einfällt,
sobald man an Schokolade denkt.
Wie aber ist es mit Kinderarbeit und der
Ausbeutung der Kakaobauern?
Daran denken wir kaum, oder?
Mehr als 1,6 Millionen Kinder
arbeiten auf Kakaoplantagen
in Ghana und der Elfenbeinküste.
Die beiden Länder produzieren
circa 60 Prozent des weltweiten Kakaos.
Auch die Lieferketten von
Deutschland und Europa sind betroffen.
Mussten Kinder schuften für
meinen Schokoriegel hier?
Es ist zumindest nicht ausgeschlossen.
Bin ich jetzt eigentlich kriminell?
Macht man sich mit
Schokoladenessen strafbar?
Ja, sagt der Journalist Teun van de Keuken
und hat sich selbst fürs
Schokoladenessen angezeigt.
Mir wurde bewusst, dass ich mich meiner
Verantwortung als Konsument stellen musste.
Nachdem ich mit einem Professor
für Strafrecht gesprochen hatte,
beschloss ich, mich selbst für den Kauf und
Verzehr von Schokolade anzuklagen.
Letztendlich hat ihn
das Gericht freigesprochen.
Van de Keuken hat daraufhin seine
eigene Schokoladenmarke gegründet.
Das Ziel von Tony’s Chocolonely ist es,
Schokolade ohne Sklaven-
und Kinderarbeit herzustellen.
Keine einfache Mission.
Selbst etablierte Schokoladenhersteller
sind bisher gescheitert.
An der Situation hat sich
in den letzten 20 Jahren
fast nichts verändert.
Damals in 2001 wurde
das Harkin-Engel-Protokoll verabschiedet,
das sich industrieweite Ziele gesetzt hatte,
Kinderarbeit aus
der Kakaoindustrie zu eliminieren.
Seitdem wurden sämtliche Deadlines,
ja, nicht wirklich getroffen
oder sind seitdem verstrichen.
Und Kinderarbeit ist nach wie vor ein sehr
großes Problem in der Industrie.
Sie nimmt sogar zu –
und das trotz wachsender Umsätze
der Schokoladenindustrie.
Diese liegen weltweit bei
über 130 Milliarden US-Dollar pro Jahr.
Warum aber ist es so schwer,
Kinderarbeit zu beenden?
Die Mehrheit der
Kakaobauern und -bäuerinnen
lebt in Armut oder sogar in extremer Armut.
Das führt dazu,
dass die Bauern auf ihre eigenen Kinder
als unbezahlte Arbeitskräfte zurückgreifen,
weil sie sich schlichtweg keine bezahlten
Arbeitskräfte leisten können.
Wenn man das
Kinderarbeitsproblem beenden will,
dann muss man also auch eine Lösung
für das Armutsproblem finden.
Niedrige Kakaopreise verschärfen die Armut.
Von dem Preis, den wir in Deutschland
für eine Tafel Schokolade ausgeben,
kommen nur etwa 6 Prozent
bei den Kakaobauern an.
Im Schnitt verdienen die rund drei Millionen
Bauern in Ghana und der Elfenbeinküste
weniger als einen Dollar am Tag
und leben damit in extremer Armut.
Der Großteil des Verkaufspreises geht an die
Schokoladenhersteller und die Supermärkte.
Ghana und die Elfenbeinküste
wehren sich dagegen.
Beide Länder verlangen 400 Dollar pro Tonne
auf den Weltmarktpreis obendrauf.
Diese Initiative finden wir sehr begrüßenswert.
Damit muss man Stand jetzt sagen,
dass die Regierungen mit dieser Initiative
deutlich mehr für die Kakaobauern und
-bäuerinnen getan haben in der Preisfrage
als alle Schokoladenunternehmen
und Zertifizierer zusammen.
Allerdings hat die Elfenbeinküste
die Erzeugerpreise für Kakao
in diesem Jahr wieder senken müssen.
Der Grund:
Der höherpreisige Kakao
hat einige Käufer abgeschreckt.
Außerdem hatte die Nachfrage nach
Kakaobohnen weltweit abgenommen.
Eine weitere Herausforderung
im Kampf gegen Kinderarbeit ist,
die Herkunft der Kakaobohnen zu kennen.
Es geht im Endeffekt darum,
wirklich zu wissen,
wo der Kakao herkommt
und sich mit den Problemen vor Ort
auch wirklich zu beschäftigen.
Jede Schokoladenfirma trägt die
Verantwortung dafür, wirklich auch zu wissen,
welche Probleme existieren und wie diese
angegangen werden können.
Die gute Nachricht:
Es gibt zunehmend Programme
gegen Kinderarbeit.
Die schlechte:
Sie erreichen bisher nur 15 Prozent
der Wertschöpfungskette.
Da bekommt meine Schokolade hier
einen ganz bitteren Nachgeschmack.